nous sommes ici à Las Vegas au CES pour
cette édition 2023 nous avons fait le
déplacement pour vous faire vivre de
l'intérieur ce plus grand salon dédié à
la tech avec évidemment
une multitude d'invités qui vont se
succéder sur ce plateau et un
prestigieux qui est avec nous bonsoir
Jean-Noël Barrault bonsoir vous êtes
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications vous
avez fait le déplacement ici au CES
parce que voilà ça devient maintenant
une institution ce ces aussi un moment
très important pour l'innovation
française parce que depuis pas mal
d'années il y a cette french Tech qui
fait le déplacement ici au CES c'est un
moment important pour l'innovation
française ce sont 170 startups
entreprises innovantes françaises qui
sont présentes c'est la principale
délégation étrangère dans ce très grand
salon d'innovation aux États-Unis on est
sur la première place du podium et cette
année la France vient d'être nommée
championne de l'innovation par le siège
j'étais avec Gary chapiro pour recevoir
le trophée
et c'est une grande satisfaction c'est
une grande fierté c'est le fruit du
travail des entrepreneurs français c'est
le fruit de tout le travail qui a été
engagé notamment depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron pour faire de la
France une grande nation
d'entrepreneuriat et d'innovation je
suis très heureux d'être là aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron qui avait fait le
déplacement on s'en souvient en 2016 il
était venu sur le plateau de l'une de
nos émissions à l'époque il était
ministre de l'Économie on s'en souvient
alors vous le disiez 170 entreprises
françaises qui représentent cette french
tech ça faisait 4 ans que un membre du
gouvernement n'était pas venu alors
évidemment au milieu tout cela il y a eu
ce covid qui a carrément arrêté toute
l'activité et ici aussi de tous les
salons c'est important pour représentant
du gouvernement de venir ici à votre
avis on voit bien que malgré le covid la
tech française a continué de se
développer y compris dans la période un
peu plus incertaine dans laquelle nous
sommes entrés puisque en 2022 la France
a connu des levés de fonds pour les
entreprises innovantes qui étaient en
croissance alors que c'est levée de
fonds étaient en décroissance dans des
pays un peu comparable comme l'Allemagne
ou même comme les États-Unis nous avons
une vente neuvième licorne avec United
au mois de décembre et donc des
fondamentaux qui sont bons en dépit de
de cette période un peu d'incertitude
donc c'est une grande satisfaction de
voir que avec cette réouverture du du
CES en format je dirais plus
traditionnel que la France était
présente en force et que la french Tech
est bien là quels sont les thèmes où on
est excellents en fait quels sont les
secteurs d'industrie où on excelle je
crois si on présente au CEMS je crois
que nous avons montré depuis 5 ans que
nous étions en capacité de développer
des grandes entreprises de services il y
en a désormais que nous utilisons
chacune et chacun tous les jours dans
notre quotidien pour prendre un
rendez-vous chez le médecin pour écouter
de la musique pour covoiturer ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'on voit se
développer une nouvelle génération
d'entreprises qui sont orientées vers
les technologies de rupture vers et en
particulier vers la Green tech je crois
qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que la
France est le premier écosystème green
tech en Europe et qui a l'a beaucoup de
potentiel alors que nous devons réussir
cette transition écologique et puis la
Green tech c'est pas que du greenwashing
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un vrai business
derrière tout ça parce qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il faut un modèle économique
derrière cette green tech non absolument
et je crois que si nous voulons réussir
la transition écologique si nous voulons
atteindre le 0 net émission en 2050 il
nous faut des solutions innovantes et
des solutions technologies il y a celles
qui sont présentées par les 170
exposants ici il y a la douzaine de de
SIO de dirigeants d'entreprises
innovantes qui m'accompagnent également
avec laquelle nous allons aller demain à
San Francisco pour rencontrer des
investisseurs intéressés par ces sujets
de Green tech et c'est un des domaines
un des secteurs dans lequel la France a
toute sa place à prendre votre agenda
aujourd'hui c'est de se balader parce
que rappelons-le puisque à Paris
évidemment c'est le soir mais la journée
ne fait que commencer ici à Las Vegas
vous allez aller à la rencontre de
toutes de tous ces entrepreneurs
français qui sont là à des dizaines de
mètres de ce plateau oui un très beau
pavillon français le coq rouge mis en
avant c'est jaloux j'en ai pas c'est une
grande satisfaction on va vous en
trouver un d'accord et puis également
des échanges plus ciblés avec des
entreprises et des investisseurs de la
Green tech comme je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure et puis un peu plus tard dans la
journée également
une participation à un événement green
tech et puis un échange avec les
francophiles puisque cette année ils
sont rassemblés ce soir pour pour un
échange à l'issue de la journée et puis
ça vous permet aussi peut-être de
rencontrer et bien tous les expatriés
non enfin alors demain vous allez aller
à San Francisco c'est intéressant de
voir aussi que voilà se déplacement
n'est pas qu'à Las Vegas on la Silicon
Valley c'est un sujet capital vous allez
aller à San Francisco à la rencontre des
entrepreneurs français aussi à San
Francisco et découvrir aussi les Google
et enfin les les qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire là-bas San Francisco pour
rencontrer les les 600 entreprises
françaises ou entreprises fondées par
des Français qui sont installés là-bas
et puis également avoir un certain
nombre d'échanges avec avec Twitter avec
Open et high avec des chercheurs à
Stanford pour réfléchir avec eux à la
question de la régulation des grandes
plateformes et la mise en oeuvre du DMA
du DSA c'est nouvelle loi européenne qui
ont été prises sous président françaises
de l'Union européenne et qui vont se
mettre en œuvre sur notre continent dans
les dans les prochains mois vous êtes
inquiet de la tournure que prend Twitter
là avec le rachat par Elon Musk c'est
pour ça que vous allez les rencontrer ou
pas c'est en partie pour ça qu'on est
convalé rencontrer je crois que
il y a encore un espoir que que Twitter
puisse rétablir une situation qui s'est
considérablement dégradée ces ces
dernières semaines qu'est-ce qui vous
fait peur en fait c'est les fake news
c'est rien rien ne me fait peur mais ce
que je souhaite c'est que Twitter qui a
pris une place dans nos dans notre
espace public dans le débat public
puisse retrouver les voies de la
responsabilité c'est ce à quoi l'appel
la réglementation européenne nouvelle le
digital le Règlement sur les services
numériques auxquels Twitter va être
assujetti et qui appelle les plateformes
à un certain niveau d'exigence en
matière de modération des contenus et
nous en avons absolument besoin parce
qu'on voit effectivement ce proliférer
dans l'espace numérique un certain
nombre de contenu qui sont soit
complètement illicites d'appel à la
haine d'apologie de l'antéchimie de
l'antisémitisme du racisme etc mais
aussi la diffusion des fake news et ça
ça suppose un dialogue constant avec ses
grandes plateformes de réseaux sociaux
pour trouver les moyens de modérer de
trouver les les voix de faire de ces
plateformes un espace public dans lequel
chacun puisse s'exprimer et vous allez
rencontrer la musk par exemple quand
vous allez ça fait partie du programme
du programme ça va être intéressant ça
va être très intéressant
un mot sur ce contexte alors évidemment
là on célèbre la tech mais voilà le
contexte géopolitique est ce qu'il est
les tensions américaines et chinoises la
guerre en Ukraine et puis aussi cette
grande démission on voit que voilà il y
a des des dizaines de milliers qui qui
disparaissent aux États-Unis on a
l'impression qu'il y a un airbag quand
même en Europe même si on a appris il y
a quelques jours que back market allait
aussi dégraisser vous êtes au courant
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet de cette de
ce contexte économique actuel de la tech
il y a une période conjoncturelle qui
qui n'est pas tout à fait simple avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes en raison du
contexte géopolitique en raison des
tensions inflationnistes mais il y a des
fondamentaux qui sont structurellement
solides pour l'Afrique fondation sont
bonnes fondations qui sont très bonnes
et vous savez comment c'est la tech aux
États-Unis a survécu à un certain nombre
de cycles à un certain nombre de crises
et je suis convaincu que la tech
française survivra à cet épisode
conjoncturel d'incertitude ceci étant
dit il y a un virage que le Président de
la République a voulu prendre qu'avec le
gouvernement avec Bruno Le Maire nous
essayons d'impulser qui est celui de
l'autonomie de la souveraineté et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous voulons
mettre le paquet sur la deeptech avec
l'ensemble des leviers qui sont entre
nos mains BPI France business France qui
œuvrent activement à la promotion de nos
entreprises françaises et puis avec
France 2030 ce grand plan qui a été
lancé l'année dernière et sur lequel
beaucoup de soutien public va être
apporté pour faire en sorte que en tout
cas dans le domaine du numérique nous
puissions prendre de l'avance sur la
question du cloud de l'intelligence
artificielle de la cyber de la quant du
Cantique et de la et de la 5G pour ne
pas être dépendant dans 10 ans de
technologie qui ne viendraient pas
d'Europe mais il y a des batailles qui
sont perdus on est d'accord Jeanne
Barrault après il faut être quand même
réaliste le Cloud ça va être compliqué
même si on a des pépites incroyables
voilà pour combattre un Amazon Google ou
un Microsoft c'est compliqué les
chipsets c'est compliqué aussi vous
parliez tout à l'heure de Green tech
c'est l'un des secteurs où on pourrait
justement gagner en souveraineté à votre
avis
c'est l'un des secteurs mais je pense
qu'il faut pas baisser les bras je pense
qu'en matière d'intelligence
artificielle en matière de cyber nous
avons de très très belles pépites nous
avons de très très bons savoir-faire
nous avons des talents qui sont
extraordinaires qui aujourd'hui par
peut-être un petit peu trop souvent
encore aux États-Unis il nous appartient
de créer les conditions pour qu'ils
restent en France et en Europe et qu'il
développe les technologies de demain
chez nous plutôt que d'aller le faire
parce que il y a sans doute de l'argent
des finances de il y a sans doute eu ces
c'est c'est dix dernières années
peut-être une une attraction plus forte
de certaines grandes entreprises
américaines mais je crois que le climat
a changé que les conditions ont évolué
et que la France est désormais avec
l'Europe évidemment en capacité d'être à
l'avant-garde de certaines de ces
technologies d'avenir et et sur celles
qui suppose des des compétences
d'ingénierie des compétences en
mathématiques avancées qui sont qui sont
particulièrement exigeante je pense au
quantique à l'IA la cyber par exemple je
crois que nous avons une carte à jouer
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre par le
plateau de takenko je vous souhaite un
bon salon merci beaucoup à vous de
belles rencontres avec toutes ces
pépites de la French Tech qui sont je
disais à quelques dizaines de mètres ici
à part merci à bientôt